well because the show is green the
Academy wanted me to recycle some jokes
from earlier in my career so here we go
what about that Gilligan's Island huh
cuz it just me or did ginger bring too
many clothes for a three-hour tour and
mrs. Howell she brought a fur coat a fur
coat to go fishing what's up with that
right anyway to present the Award for
Best Animated Feature the voice of Thea
Princess Fiona from the Shrek movies
Cameron Diaz
animated features have come a long way
since Walt Disney was awarded a special
Oscar in 1938 for a significant screen
innovation that pioneered a great new
entertainment field the film was Snow
White and the Seven Dwarves and those
days each dwarf was lovingly drawn by
hand from bashful's glowing red cheeks
and grumpy's frown to Debbie's droopy
drawers I got to say that at new Oscars
by the way this year's animators work
their magic on computers with a lot of
imagination and a few deaf clicks of the
keys they realize talking cars
tapping penguins and a house that haunts
itself here are the dynamically
dimensional nominees cars John Lasseter
happy meet George Miller
monster how Gil Kenan
the Academy rules specify that animated
characters must remain in their seats
only real people can accept the award so
please be animated okay and the Oscar
goes to see happy feet
this is the first Academy Award and for
the nomination for George Miller
previously nominated for writing
Lorenzo's oil and writing and producing
babe his fondest memory was watching
Robin Williams bring the script to life
oh gosh I I asked my kids what should I
say they said thank all the men for
we're wearing penguin suits they gave me
they gave me lucky coin
lucky penguin but my real good luck was
to work with hundreds and hundreds of
amazing people a wonderful cast great
artists computer whiz whizzes studios
that were passionate people who cut
trailers dubbed the movie got into the
theaters and on their behalf I thank the
Academy for this thank you
you